all right guys
bang bang plane is here she also happens
to be my wife but she is the founder
of the profile every single wednesday
she writes
a profile dossier which is basically a
deep dive
on a successful person she goes and
scours the internet she finds all sorts
of articles
interviews videos podcasts whatever she
can
learns as much as she can about that
person and then writes it all down to
save
you me and all of the other readers time
i really enjoy reading them so she's
here on the podcast
we're going to talk about some of the
people that she's written recent once on
what's up
what's up how are you great great i
haven't seen you in uh
five minutes i know all right let's
start with
frank abagnale how you say it abagnale
frank abagnale yes that is how you say
this is the guy who
uh catch me if you can yes right it was
the movie was created because of him yes
it was
leonardo dicaprio was based his
character was based on
the real frank abagnale okay i've seen a
google talk by frank abagnale
it's very good i highly highly suggest
it um but he's got kind of a crazy
story he was basically a criminal and
then ended up helping the government
he was a con man of all con men he was
an impersonator so before he was the
king of the congress
conmen yes okay but it was funny because
you want to say like oh yeah he was like
a con man whatever he was a 16 year old
kid
he was just really really smart and
he um all before he was 21 years old he
impersonated
an airline pilot a doctor a bureau of
prisons agent
a sociology professor and an attorney
and he did it so believably that people
were like
oh yeah that's a doctor
and so what was the purpose for doing
this was he like stealing money from
people or was he just literally doing it
to see if he could
so basically uh this all happened
after his parents had a devastating
divorce and he ran away from home
when you run away from home at age 16
thank you when you um when you
run away from home at age 16 you need to
figure out how to make money
he figured out quickly that he stop it
i'm fixing her microphone go ahead um
he he didn't kind of aim to become one
of the most famous imposters
ever uh but he ended up like he was
forging checks he was doing little
things and i think
his frame of mind was more so i'm clever
they're not gonna catch me
i'm beating them at their own game then
it was
you know uh i want to be a criminal but
he basically said like
the deeper he got into it the harder it
was to get out
um but he says like in our society
people
judge people uh by you know you judge a
book by its cover
you're judged based on what you wear and
how you appear so he just learned the
game oh if i put on a suit and tie
i could enter this fancy party i can
meet some people i can just observe them
he would
literally go to the lobby and observe
attorneys and see how they acted
and then impersonate them so when you
think about
studying a criminal that's not exactly
the person i would think that you would
go
and learn something from what did you
think you learned from them i learned a
lot
okay and um if you've seen the movie
catch me if you can you know that
eventually
um he gets caught by the fbi he gets
caught in france
spends some time in a french prison
comes back to the united states and
starts working
with the fbi on uh check forging and
trying to like
catch cyber criminals so basically he
becomes a rat
no he does not become a rat he didn't
rat on anybody he's helping the fbi
find criminals who are really good at
what they do so he switched
teams he switched teams okay but in his
mind he was like i'm basically trying to
repent for what i did and this is my way
of paying it off he was with the fbi for
decades and i'm assuming he caught a lot
of people
he did i'm sure i don't know the extent
of it
yeah um did he go to jail
he went to jail in france but i think he
was
in the u.s they're like you don't have
to go to jail but you have to switch
teams yes
wow i i don't know how i feel about that
why like
if you're a criminal even if you're
helping the government now do you just
not go to jail at all again like he
didn't kill people it's not like he was
like
a murderer who suddenly is like oh i'm
going to help the u.s government
the government no he i mean he forged
checks and like
got people you know took their money and
stole it's not good
he did steal yeah okay i think
i don't know um but basically the whole
idea is like
okay well you're really smart obviously
he um
like the ways that he would um
run away from the cops and the fbi for
years is
actually incredible like what hold on uh
oh no what is an example of how frank
abagnale
would run away from the police so
um he
i forgot there was oh okay okay okay he
managed to escape from police custody
twice
once from a taxiing airliner and one's
from a us federal penitentiary
but how did he do it oh long story you
gotta go read it oh
okay all right let's move on to the next
person dolly parton
you didn't we didn't get to the lesson i
learned from okay what was the lesson
well a lot so okay so basically
frank um explains that anybody can be
really really good at um becoming like
he basically says observation is a
superpower when he
looks at someone on the street who's
wearing a suit and tie
he can tell like that guy's a
businessman who works at goldman sachs
and the guy who's dressed exactly like
him i know that he's a drug dealer
and the way he knows is by the little
tiny cues that the people give off
most of us don't pay enough attention to
the shoes to the way they
um carry themselves to to know so
actually you're much why are you
laughing at me
the only drug dealers that wear suits
and ties are pharmaceutical
representatives
[Laughter]
anyway but um he he's able to say like
you're very likely to get scammed and
conned because you don't pay enough
attention
so if you start paying attention you
might not be the victim of a con
okay anything else you learn from them i
mean a lot
that's probably the best one yeah all
right dolly parton time
dolly parton time so dolly parton is
just a country singer i thought
and then and then you basically broke
down her whole life she's been married
forever
yup nobody knows anything about her
husband really
and she's actually like a savage
businesswoman who
plays kind of dumb when she's
in public when everybody else is playing
checkers
she's so good she's so she couldn't beat
me in chess but go ahead
she's so good so first of all what you
need to know about dolly partner is she
was born in extreme poverty
she was one of 12 kids born in a
one-bedroom
log cabin in the mountains of tennessee
and um and she grew up without
electricity think about 12 kids in a
one-bedroom log cabin
in tennessee sounds like they had a lot
of fun
and when she moved to nashville she by
the way she met her husband the first
day she moved to nashville
at a laundromat and um
basically she was trying to be this
country singer country star
and they were like you're very rough
around the edges because she came from
like a really really poor
uh place and i watched this documentary
and they were saying like she would use
language that was very crude that like
ladies didn't use
um but they liked her because it gave
her character
she kind of played dumb she was honest
yeah and um and they told her dolly
she was like oh by the way i'm gonna get
married and they're like no you're not
you have this like sex appeal you're
gonna play into this image
basically your career is going to be
over if you get married and
like men can't like you know fantasize
like you're single you have sex appeal
whatever
and she was like okay and then she
didn't tell anybody
they got secretly married at the
courthouse and a year later she went
back and they were like oh no you can't
get married like whatever
and she's like by the way i've been
married for a year and you didn't know
and i have a great career so
what's your point she she does things
like that she
um you know a lot of people are like
they want to do use stereotypes and make
fun of her
um so they're like oh well like if they
want to make fun of the fact that she
has a lot of plastic surgery
or she has like really big fake boobs or
whatever and she and when they
make a joke about it they'll be like uh
oh well you're fake or whatever and
she'll say
i may be fake but i'm real in all the
like places that matter
and she'll kind of she's already
expecting it and she
she uh like it tosses it back to them
and the whole point is like you can only
feel shame
if you allow them to shame you she
doesn't care
is it fair to say that most famous
successful people did not get lucky
and they're actually very very
intelligent know exactly what they're
doing
yes like she's kanye west
is probably much more intelligent than
people give him credit for
i think some people get lucky but
then it catches up to them and they fall
into obscurity because they're not
willing to be strategic how much money
do we think dolly parton makes do we
know
oh i'm i'm not i'm not sure
but like like do we think that she's
worth 100 mil
10 million a billion probably like
closer to 100 million
yeah if i had to guess she um she's
actually really philanthropic
uh she because her dad didn't know how
to read
she started an organization called the
imagination library in 1995.
today her program spans five countries
five countries and gifts over one
million free books
each month to kids around the world and
today
she's donated more than 140 million
books
wow 140 million books yeah that's wild
to kids all around the world all right
what'd you learn from her
um i learned a lot by the way if you
want to read the dossiers you can go to
readtheprofile.com readtheprofile.com so
okay so here's a fun one you probably
didn't know
i learned me okay so she
you know at the time was kind of
building her career she was still
relatively young
and imagine your dolly parton
and you have this song that you wrote
that you sang called i will always love
you
and in the 70s elvis presley wanted to
record her song but his manager
wanted half the publishing rates and she
said
no i that's not fair i wrote it i sing
it it's my song
and she wouldn't budge on the position
so they couldn't come to terms
and she said no and people were like wow
like
oh my god she's a woman she should be
honored that elvis presley wants to
record her song
and here's what she said she said i
never thought of it as being about being
a man or a woman i thought of
about it as being an artist and a writer
and a person of strong will
so she just like wasn't willing to budge
on this one
thing and she said it broke my heart to
say no but i was willing to suffer that
temporary disappointment and heartache
than to live with something that i knew
was wrong um so yeah so then
whitney houston as we know i will always
love you
became famous that that became her song
she became famous with that song
uh and dolly says um i'm i'm happy that
you know she
became that would people associate that
song with her
as long as um as long as i'm still
making the money
so as long as dolly parton's getting
based you don't get who gets credit yeah
i mean she's focused on the right thing
for them because when you hear that song
you think of uh whitney houston not
uh dolly party the dolly parton the
savage is the one who actually made it
i love it all right next speaking of uh
opportunistic person uh kris jenner
who i actually think is probably one of
the most intelligent business people on
the planet
uh is the mother and
manager to like a gazillion kardashians
i literally don't know how many there
are she manages them all uh you showed
me the trailer
one time for like the original
kardashian show and there was literally
like a hundred of them
how many are there oh okay so there's
like i think five kids
if i'm correct so oh it's like a hundred
percent boys there's like a hundred
kardashian girls kim
courtney we we don't have to do public
math
i don't know there's like kylie well
so never mind okay i'm not gonna get
into the family dynamics
sorry six children six children i wrote
it out what did she do
before she became the person that people
know now
sorry what did she do before she okay so
she has kind of a complicated life um
she was 17 years old when she started
dating
robert kardashian okay who was a
successful attorney 11 years older at
the time
right okay so we got 28 year old hooking
up with a 17 year old exactly so
not exactly legal in today's world right
so at the time i'm not sure but probably
not legal and in not you know her
parents looked down upon it so they were
just friends
she was 17. so she was like thank you
for your advances
i cannot pursue this so
sure she did she turned him down and
pursued her career
as a flight attendant because she wanted
to see the world
uh they ultimately reunited and she
married him at age
22 a very a much more appropriate age um
and then eight years later she realized
she was a housewife with four kids
so she had a little affair with a soccer
player
so then her and robert after he found
out so chris
jenner cheated on her husband right okay
so then her husband
robert kardashian found out and they
went through a really ugly
public divorce in which he canceled her
credit cards and left her broken alone
so suddenly
she went from a rich housewife he was
famous and she wasn't
right okay right okay so then shortly
thereafter
she met then bruce jenner on a blind
date
and bruce jenner at the time was kind of
uh
like a failed star i mean he like he was
an olympian he was an olympian but his
olympic career cousin was kind of like
stalling like he he was
out of the olympics whatever so she was
like he's kind of like a poor man's uh
um robert kardashian like robert was a
star he was
so so she ended up becoming she was
bored right so she ended up becoming
bruce's
agent literally putting together like
these like press packets and sending
them to press and being like
he's an olympian like if you have a
speaking gig at your conference he'll
come speak
so she ended up making him a lot of
money that way were they hooking up then
yeah they they met on a blind date got
married shortly thereafter
and then she like started helping him oh
wow she married him actually
a month after her divorce was finalized
yeah um helping him so they had two
daughters
kendall and kylie okay kylie is yep uh
uh before their family landed
the the young one yeah so she she had
two kids with
brewster oh and the other ones were
before got it okay got it
um so so then okay so basically
long story short kris jenner and her
daughters um
courtney and kim had these like clothing
stores
in la and they really wanted to be like
into fashion
and they wanted to open up stores in l.a
whatever and
um let's not fool ourselves nothing pops
off until kim has a sex tape
well so they get a tv deal
and then oh they got the tv deal before
the sex tape yes
interesting yes and then the sex tape
came out and here's what how one new
york times columnist put it
as a parent kris jenner was concerned
for her daughter
but as her manager she thought well hot
diggity
so do we think that sex tape was real
like they
they uh did not expect that to come out
or was that
a pre-planned leak
to be famous not i don't buy into the
conspiracy theories but
be my guest i i didn't even know there's
a conspiracy theory so anyway
i mean again luck or whatever
but now two or three of her children are
billionaires like
you cannot go from sex tape to
billionaire as hard as you strive
a lot of people who try to do that is
kris jenner a billionaire i don't
think so no she takes twenty percent
isn't it ten percent i think i heard
i think it was ten percent is it ten
percent pretty sure yeah
she takes a ten percent cut from each of
her children's earnings
10 is not that bad yeah she says the
industry average is 20
which is why i remembered it but got it
yeah so she takes 10
because they're her kids so it's like a
family friend's discount yeah in it
if you know anything about kristin or
she works like she does not
one of her famous quotes is um if i
call you and somebody and you say no or
if you call somebody and they say no
then you're talking to the wrong person
like she will find a way
to get you there um what i what i
learned about her is
something that i myself have experienced
um
you don't need business school to get a
business school education
so basically even though kris jenner was
a housewife
of this you know robert kardashian she
found herself
at parties at concerts at ballets operas
around these really successful business
people
and so she learned from them she
overheard things she asked questions
and she said i got married to robert
kardashian when i was 22 years old
everybody that i was surrounded by for
two decades was at the top of their game
in the entertainment business so she
literally had a front row seat to
someone like the brightest minds in
entertainment
whether you like it or not you're gonna
pick up on things and if you're smart
you're gonna use it
all right i agree with all that what's
next in uh our lessons of kris jenner
what'd you learn from her
oh what else so every year she um
has an annual check-in with her kids but
i find it really interesting because she
she admits that she herself is a control
f
she admits that she's a control freak
and she loves controlling the narrative
but if you know one thing about the
kardashian family
is that they've been through some [ __ ]
but they have never made themselves the
victim
ever like they always kind of in the
most
like crises of crises i mean
kim kardashian got robbed at gunpoint in
france sex tape
robberies of all the things conversions
of
they're never on the side of victim
they're always somehow and that's like a
knock against
you know uh chris jenner is like oh it's
always a business opportunity but i
don't think so i think like
she talks about like i'm a mom first but
then i'm not gonna let my kid just
swallow in this and like
you know lose sight of what's important
can we ask the important questions
what what is going on with the uh kim
kardashian kanye west why are they
messing with my guy kanye
we're we're not going to get into that
right now but what is not that
i don't know oh i think kanye was right
i don't even are they disagreeing or is
this amicable
i don't know all right kanye and that's
the other thing i i've been watching the
last season of the kardashians which
after like
20 years it's finally coming to an end
and
they keep they've always like whenever a
spouse
does not want to participate in the show
they don't make them for a while kanye
wanted to be in it then he was like no i
don't want to be in it anymore
fine they don't even talk about him and
when
kim was going through the divorce in
this season
they kept it out like they showed her on
the phone they showed her upset
but they never kind of like aired their
dirty laundry
and even in a family that public to have
some privacy i think is really
interesting kanye west is still right
i'm sure that they're screwing them
somehow
they're it's they're colluding they're
colluding what's up guys
bang bang i hope you're enjoying this
conversation but before we go any
further i want to quickly tell you about
today's sponsor
blockfy blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com pomp go check it
out and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it all
right daniel eck
daniel eck is the uh spotify
founder and ceo uh incredibly
intelligent
uh has built uh amazing business in the
audio space
now going really heavy into podcasting
went on an absolute
acquisition tear some may say what's up
with him
okay so he's fascinating why he's
probably one of my favorite ceos
you could you know you could meet a worm
on the street like oh this worm was
really fascinating and you literally
could come back with like three things
like damn that worm is pretty right yeah
go ahead
i was gonna say a savage comeback but i
didn't go ahead
that's why i found you fascinating oh
because i like the worm on the street
okay
just like i can find anybody fascinating
oh you're genuinely fascinated
okay you're not bothering me whatsoever
whether you think i'm first
right now you have very like uh closed
off body language so i'm just saying
um all right so daniel eck
listen there's other people in the room
right now don't make me shut this
podcast off and we can
uh open up your body language like we're
here to chat
no we're not here we are on a timer
let's go you're you're
pontificating on things that don't
matter in 2006
daniel eck asked himself the question
which is nearly impossible to answer
do you have an answer for this question
what is better than free
what is better than free if you do
things and get paid for it
damn daniel damn daniel look at that
okay you're gonna ask me easy questions
bring the hard ones where's the s.a.t
question
so here's here's a fun fact
at the time in 2006 online music piracy
was at
like thriving in sweden in sweden right
but because it was thriving it was
thriving in sweden because of
government-mandated broadband and the
country had one of the fastest
um internet speeds in the world which
allowed people to easily
download songs and stuff on the internet
in seconds
but daniel like is smart and you realize
wait a second but that's not
that's not true for the rest of the
world if you're in the us and you want
to download some sketchy music or not
sketch me you want to download
music off of a sketchy website that you
didn't pay for for free
it would take hours right do you
remember because
um anyway so he he decided that the
thing that would be better than free
is something that could be legal and
free
and fast and he legal free and fast
sorry yes okay um
so he said i had this idea of the kind
of product i wanted to see in the world
what if we can build something that
makes it feel like
you had all the world's music on your
hard drive and if we can create that
feeling we'll have built something
much better than privacy so um
anyway so basically he said that if he
could offer something really
fast and people would be able to
press play and it would play immediately
then people would be willing to pay for
it okay what do you think is the biggest
lesson you learned from him
oh um okay so i think the biggest lesson
and one that
i've actually thought about in my daily
life
um is that he he's very busy right like
he has a massive company now
uh but he typically starts working
around 10 a.m
because and not only does he start at 10
a.m he also limits his calendar to three
to four meetings a day
and this is based on what he read of
paul graham's idea of a maker schedule
versus a manager's schedule
so when you're operating on a manager's
schedule your calendar
has all the meetings in the world you're
on other people's time
but if you're a maker you devote long
chunks of time to work on creative
problem
and they generally prefer to use time in
units
of half a day that allow them to work on
longer term meteor
initiatives than have them sliced up in
little chunks
so that's how he schedules his day and
every meeting he walks into he knows the
exact
role he is playing and he knows you what
do you need from me
in this meeting he likes to know that in
advance when he goes in he can make
decisions quickly
i like that a lot i also bet that his
meetings are much shorter than most
people
yeah and he literally like half the day
he'll reserve for
strategic thinking because that is the
role of him a ceo right
yeah do you are you long spotify
podcasting
so fascinating now i want to be they
made a bunch of acquisitions
on this podcast we put our opinions on
the line
well but apple just launched that
sleekness so do you think spotify
podcast no music yes okay i actually
have a nuanced answer tell me
spotif spotify will continue to grab
more and more of the podcast market
share
but they will never be able to unseat
apple i agree
agree yep all right next
one of my favorite people in the world
of business mr
tyler perry also known as madea
[Music]
so when he was little a teacher
asked him what he wanted to be when he
grew up and he answered with a one word
answer even though he didn't know any at
the time
he said billionaire what a boss
what a boss and so she told him that he
would never make it because he was poor
and he was black and he said even as a
child there was something in me that
said that's not true
don't believe that and what is he now a
billionaire
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the part
that i like about tyler perry though
is that uh he owns what's called tyler
perry enterprise
at all he owns a hundred percent no
investors all him
billion dollars alone just through that
he has amassed one of the most
valuable individually owned libraries in
hollywood
right now that happened because a bunch
of people when he was creating these
plays and these movies people would turn
them down
and he was like okay fine well i'll own
a hundred percent then like he had no
choice
but to own a hundred percent and now his
motto has become
own your stuff own your business own
your way he's really big on ownership
and he learned that from oprah yeah
oprah
is a absolute animal too i love it
yeah so all right tyler perry owns 100
yeah everything he does including
doesn't he own a bunch of real estate in
atlanta
yes at some point they like helped him
buy
in 2019 he opened the largest privately
owned motion picture studio in the us it
is a
330 acre former confederate army base
that now houses 12
sound stages each of which is named
after an iconic african-american figure
and he shot that's awesome the first
movie he shot there was black panther
it's cool he just gets it right and you
can just tell he's doing things his own
way
yeah and it feels like that's why he's
so successful
yeah um so so i like him because
you know when people are like who was
your mentor growing up and like who did
you aspire to be he was like
i didn't know my mentor he was like i
would come home from school i would turn
on the television
and i would watch the oprah show and to
him she was more influential in his life
even though he didn't know her because
she talked
she owned the oprah show she owned like
the
uh her own partially at the time oh
really
yeah okay well there's a great if anyone
wants to learn more about oprah they
should go to the acquired
fm podcast they have an entire episode
on oprah winfrey
probably one of the best podcast
episodes i've ever listened to they do a
really really good job
and and the reason i like that is
because that's
the whole premise of the profile you
don't actually have to know the people
you learn from you can still learn from
their mistakes
their failures and their successes just
by studying them
do you feel like tyler perry would be
more successful
or less successful if he was starting
today given the internet
and digital media a hundred percent more
successful why
oh my god like he would he would hold
these plays and the way he would get the
word out is through like flyers and like
imagine
having facebook or twitter or like you
could mobilize
still on facebook okay you could mobile
i was thinking of facebook groups
you could mobilize people on a level
that like you never it was all local
then you know
all right next person last person
probably the kindest human on planet
earth
kiana reed and and by the way
the only thing i know about him before
you went and did this was
if you've ever seen the movie hardball
you ever seen it
no hardball he basically is a coach he
goes and he coaches like an inner city
uh baseball team
and at one point he literally is in the
dugout and he starts singing big papa
and he starts waving his hands you
didn't know him from the matrix
nah i don't watch that stuff i knew it
from the matrix
so you watched the matrix you sat down
and watched the whole nature so yes
because it was constantly on tbs when we
moved to the united states and i had to
watch it
yeah well you weren't red pilled when i
met you so
exactly make sure you catch my eye okay
yeah
i did catch your eye that's why we're
married
go ahead tell me about kiana reeves help
okay
so i didn't know i mean how lucky is she
so i didn't know anything about keanu
except for the fact that people had
always said he is known for doing these
random acts of kindness
so uh there's a video on the internet a
viral video of him
uh seeing a woman with a large bag and
he got up
from his seat on the subway which he
rides even though he's worth like 300
million dollars
he gets up offers her the seat she sits
down he just like acts like nothing ever
happened
another time he was caught uh for hours
hanging out with a homeless man
um and just like chilling telling
stories they were eating together
um and then uh and then another time
uh he jumped out of a car to autograph a
sign
he saw on a fan's lawn it's just
like he he does these are these pr
moments right there no no no no no
they're not like the yeah they're not so
anyway so he's just always doing random
little things
um but what a lot of people don't know
about keanu
is that he actually he's really really
big into giving back
um and he does much bigger acts of
kindness
and i believe it's because of all the
tragedy that he's been through
what tragedy so when he was not so first
of all he had dyslexia he always
struggled in school when he was nine
his dad left the family he was raised by
his mom
um and and he grew up with a sister then
his sister got leukemia
then when he grew up uh things were just
starting to go his way like the matrix
was doing really well
and then um and then he
had a longtime girlfriend and their baby
was born stillborn at eight months
that was a really big tragedy for him
and then
18 months later his girlfriend died and
tragically in a car accident
so it's like time and time and time
again and then you find out
literally you have to find out that
there are no reports on this he
does it anonymously like he tries to
keep everything really quiet
but he's like a massive donor to um
children's
cancer hospitals and research and all
that kind of stuff
um and uh
and then he's also known for for example
um
the matrix series he gave up a
percentage of the profits that he was
getting
to give them to the costume design team
and the special effects team because
he's like they're the ones who made the
movie
i didn't make the movie they deserve to
be paid uh profits off the
uh of the series too he did that he
shaved his salary by a few million
dollars for the devil's advocate
just because he wanted to get al pacino
so they're like we can oh why's al
pacino being so damn greedy
come on now let's split it a little bit
here i'll give up a little bit you give
up a little bit
and he did the same thing on the
replacements to be able to work with
gene
hackman gene heckman why are you being
greedy come on i give up a little bit
you give up a little bit
cheese so it's just like those things
that kind of tell you what type of
person he was and i'll never forget i
read a profile on him
and the reporter was like so why are you
like not public about
you know um or well she she said
something like are you not public
about uh the fact that you make
donations to children's cancer hospitals
uh because uh you know you're i forget
what the question was like
because you you you want people to find
out in like a pyramid he goes no i do it
because it's private and that's why i
don't attach my name to like it has
nothing to do
with pr or publicity or anything like
that it was just
such a i don't know i just really like
him what's the most surprising fact
about him that people won't know
well i just said a bunch of ones that
people don't know but we know those now
because we've been listening
oh okay um
okay
oh okay that was a really weird noise
um all right so
okay so
his father leaving his father also got
arrested for like heroin and cocaine
spent a bunch of time in prison
uh that really affected him and every
time in every interview
people ask him about it so every time he
responds so for example this in this
profile they asked about how his
father's absence affected him and he
said
gosh in so many ways i'm not filling
that in i'm not
and he never talks about his childhood
he never talks about his parents
um and he makes no apologies for like
preserving his
privacy and the reporter kept pushing
and he said
i just really don't want to tell you and
that was it
i feel like that's fair yeah but you you
know like i feel like if you're a
celebrity and you're out there promoting
a movie
they tell you like talk about everything
it's good people like the vulnerable
they like
and he's like this is not for you to
know right i'm here promoting the matrix
but i'm not going to talk about my
father's absence
he should have just pulled out two hands
to be like red pill blue pill and see
what the
the journalist said all right what's
your favorite part about doing these uh
profile dossiers
my favorite thing is trying to
understand people without ever meeting
them
and i do that by um
well first of all a lot of observation
you'd be surprised at how much you can
learn about someone
by watching them so there's a ton of
videos of these people giving interviews
whatever
um watching somebody like keanu for
example he's always kind of like
he's kind of like um again body language
is very closed off he
he doesn't appear to be like the life of
the party
when you look at somebody like martha
stewart
she is she's posting thirst she's
posting thirst drafts on instagram
it's about how they present themselves
and then also it's about what they say
when you hear something over and over
and over again but then
they say it but then their actions don't
match their words you're like ah so
you're kind of like putting on a show
for him it's consistently i will not
speak about my private life
um and i just really like people
okay read the profile.com yes
now that we've been in miami i've wait
what what's your favorite thing about
the profile
i just like learning i you do all the
work and then i get to take away all the
lessons it's like the best thing ever
literally and for those that are
confused
i'm a paying member
thank you i appreciate you i was the
second support
paying member ever yeah somebody beat me
somebody beat me
which is nonsense but i was the second
paying member ever
and i've continued to pay high loyalty
very high retention user right here
uh but i know i like it that you go and
you do all the work you find all the
podcasts you distill it all down i just
have to read one
email bam i feel like i got all the
value you did all the work
that is how life works it's amazing
uh readprofile.com yes leave everyone
with one pro and one con of miami before
we go
you have to pick one positive and one
negative so far of living in miami one
pro
is that i've been pleasantly surprised
at the
caliber of conversation and people that
are in miami i've already made so many
friends
and like real friends not just you know
fake friends
okay um and then and then khan
yeah um i i sweated today i was hot
you sweated that's a con yeah okay
it was hot out there well that's it for
today
read the profile dot com go follow
plynna at what's your twitter account
now at paulina underscore marinova
all right we'll do it again sometime